so today we're into someone else's
garden instead of mine yeah and it
doesn't look very familiar to me no yeah
pretty different we've got four lovely
it's freezing though not good what's the
temperature sport or degrees so pretty
much just above freezing
nice package cheers yeah it's pretty
cold today so you know screw it up a
little bit yeah so look is one two three
bull shriveling cold only find one gun
and what and I've never done it so okay
so you get a fire some sort of pistol on
door yeah the very first yeah this is a
momentous occasion here first thanks to
what we got here we're using a different
camera usually we use the Phantom flex
which shoots 2500 frames a second in
Full HD 5000 7 20 P that's just not fast
enough for guns so what's this there so
this is the V 16 10 which does 18,000
frames a second 18,000 how many team how
many times slower than real time is that
there's about 750 yeah 750 times third
the real time so so gonna get some good
underwater gun action yeah we should be
able to catch some slow bullets as well
we might even go a little bit slower as
well by lowering the resolution to a
standard F so we get 27,000 second
that's 27,000 last vote
really on the other career yep this
might be one of the weirdest sights I've
ever seen that you know you can actually
just hold it you can be above the water
okay
that sounded awesome and water that
sounded cool it was like a metallic
sound it was like yeah it sounded wicked
oh yeah here Lister pistol bullet
9-millimeter as you can see the rifling
in the barrel of the pistol has engaged
in the outside soft copper on the on the
bullet itself and that is to impart spin
on the bullet to make it travel further
and also cause better operation for let
me ask you let me ask you a question
yeah is this the first time you've ever
been smart in a slow mo guys with you I
think yeah when it comes to guns so it's
the first day of fired of weapon under
water and been smart
alright alright what we're gonna find
next we're gonna get revolver on the go
see what that looks like how do you
think it would be different
there'll be more guests coming out
between the revolver and the ego the
more guests going out here I like the
color yes bling right pretty pimp yeah
more guests coming out here and there
should be quite a lot coming out because
it's only a short valve weapon so you
put interesting let's go on
yeah revolver of pimps alright we're
gonna fire a hollow-point on this one
you cool with that damn alright just
lower yourself in yeah
three two one
did it that should have mushroomed out I
hope people I hope people don't take the
audio from that and replace it with
something that's definitely gonna thank
you what I'd dad just good what soon
good days filming down yeah it's pretty
cold how long you been the what told you
think how are probably please been in
and out in and out something I someone
get back in good this your oh well I
thought that looks bloody awesome what
did that yeah it's freezing and I've got
really told what you knew and that's
well thanks to you destined for letting
us use this awesome mirror rate he's
actually gonna go and shoot an ak-47 on
this channel right now yeah pretty cool
huh
so I mean it was funny when you did
hello again just sneaking this in the
end that video was shot about eight
months ago
and I did a pretty terrible job in that
last segment of promoting Destin's
channel so I'm gonna do a better job
right now this video could have been
done without Destin those are his
pistols we flew to Alabama to shoot it
which is where he lives
he built the giant periscope mirror rig
that we used and he also got hold of the
amazing camera so huge thanks to
destined to make
this one possible I imagine most of you
have heard of Destin but if you haven't
he has a channel called smarter every
day which he should definitely subscribe
to and on his video he's done the ak-47
but he explains all the science behind
it so basically everything that's
happening underwater while you get those
domes that kind of bouncing off each
other like this all the science behind
it is explained so if you're interested
as to why the bullet does what it does
and the water and why the water reacts
that way definitely go watch this video
is extremely interesting all right
thanks nice warm dry shoes on don't you
get for bringing loafers to anywhere
that was your way of coming in for that
was your shoe of choice yep yep
excellent yeah